hi I'm Alexis and I'm the senior food
specialist here at tasty today I'm gonna
show you how to make my pulled pork
stuffed milk funds so to start these
milk funds so you want to make at Ang's
on so that's the starter which you're
going to end up chilling in the fridge
for an hour it's really easy to make it
comes together really easily and that's
gonna help give the milk buns this
really incredible soft luscious flavor
so once your starters cool you're gonna
start making the dough the dough is
really easy to make but I think the
crucial point about this is that it's
really sticky and that you need to knead
it for like 20 minutes I know it sounds
like a long time and it's gonna seem
like it's not coming together but if you
keep kneading it it'll gradually form a
ball that you can work with so when
you're making bread you always want to
use a starter in this case we're making
a Tang song which is a really easy
starter to make it just has bread flour
whole milk and water other starters
might have yeast that we're gonna add
that later in the process kneading the
dough for a long time is going to help
produce the gluten which is gonna make a
really Airy fluffy bread I played around
with a few recipes when I was developing
this and when I first made it like do
you really need
need it for this long and you really do
in order to get that fluffiness you
really need to take your time with the
dough after you've you needed the dough
you're gonna let it rise for an hour
hour and a half that's a really basic
step in bread making after the dough is
risen it's time to divide it into
individual portions so once you divide
the dough up you can flatten a piece out
so that it's like a big and then add
your filling of choice
I had a full pork just because I loved
it but you could add any philony walk at
that point you're gonna pinch each side
up to slowly seal it then flip it over
so that the seal is on the bottom and
that the smooth side is on the top so
for Thanksgiving I actually had milk
buttons rather than dinner rolls and
everyone loves them I just feel like the
best thing ever put the four buns back
in baking pans of course you want really
beautiful glossy buns so brush them with
an egg wash and then you're gonna bake
it you could also add toppings like
seeds you could use like in everything
bagel spice you can really get creative
here
I like that sesame seeds I think it just
adds a little bit of extra flavor it's
really aesthetically pleasing you could
even add flaky sea salt really whatever
you want
you only need to bake it for 25-30
minutes until they're nice and
golden-brown
at this point you're done just let them
cool pop them out and go crazy
I love getting milk buns when I go out
to eat and this was actually the first
time I've ever made the recipe it was
really really fun to make I think the
joy of this is that you can stuff it
like I did with pork or you can put in
other ingredients other types of meat
vegetables or you can just have buns by
themselves I think no puns are so good
because they're so fluffy it's really
like the fluffiest bread you can get so
you can make this recipe for a dinner
party if you just want to flame buns on
the side you can make it for a picnic to
bring it to the beach I mean
are great for barbecue there's so many
options
[Music]